quick a si nous bonjour à tous je me
présente mon nom c'est jello niort
mathias je suis fièrement de la nation
des pekuakamiulnuatsh et de la nation
anishnabe
permettez moi de vous souhaiter la
bienvenue à ma toute première chronique
que j'ai intitulé cap a title kapatakan
c'est le mot en innu pour parler du
portage un portage pour ceux qui
connaissent moins c'est le moment quand
on doit accoster avec notre canot sur la
rive pour pouvoir franchir un obstacle
ou pour passer d'un cours d'eau à un
autre à pied avec le canot dans mon beau
mais en sait autant les inouk désigné
nabi mais ils ont eu à faire de nombreux
portages quand il parcourait le
territoire
parfois les portages de déco des fois
ils et elles ont des fois il était
facile d'autres fois plus difficile
malgré tout on s'entend pour dire que
c'est en parcourant les portages qu'ils
arrivent à se rendre jusqu'à destination
notre destination à nous celle que je
vous propose c'est celle de la
réconciliation et l'autodétermination
deux thématiques que j'affectionne
particulièrement
c'est donc à travers ces deux
thématiques là que je vais aborder le
temps d'un reportage
l'actualité et les enjeux autochtones
qui m'interpelle
pour ma première chronique je me suis
vraiment questionné par rapport aux
sujets que je voulais abordable
finalement je me suis dit que ça
pourrait être intéressant de parler du
canadien de montréal
le jeu vous entendre vous vous dites oui
mais dit gg c'est quoi le lien entre le
canadien de montréal qui les autochtones
mais pour ce qui était peut-être pas au
courant la fin de semaine dernière le
canadien a annoncé que dorénavant avant
chaque match à domicile
il y aura un message de reconnaissance
territoriale qui serait lui en gros ce
que le message dit c'est que le canadien
souhaite reconnaître les gagnants
guingamp la nation mohawk pour leur
hospitalité sur le territoire non cd sur
lequel il se trouve montréal
le canadien emboîte donc le pas de
plusieurs autres organisations qui ont
déjà mis en place la reconnaissance
territoriale il ya des équipes sportives
qu'il faisait déjà
ici au québec on ne veut pas penser aux
universités ou encore à certaines
municipalités comme la ville de montréal
qui reconnaissent de territoire
damnation sur lequel il trouve
la reconnaissance territoriale c'est un
geste qui s'inscrit dans la volonté de
réconciliation
c'est un geste symbolique oui mais c'est
un geste quand même
loge un problème c'est quand la
réconciliation s'arrête là à un niveau
symbolique
c'est bien beau de reconnaître les
terres sur lesquelles tu trouves mais si
tu poses pas d'actions je vois pas
tellement ce que ça change
en gros on peut dire qu'il ya deux types
de réconciliation et la réconciliation
de surface celle qui est pertinent mais
qui restent symboliques comme la
reconnaissance territoriale puis à la
reconnaissance plus concret la
réconciliation plus conclut celle qui va
plus loin comme de donner une tribune à
un jeune autochtone dans un grand média
ce qui est intéressant c'est quand on
pense à cette autre niveau de
réconciliation au niveau plus concret
dans les actions qui ont un impact
direct sur les milieux sur les individus
faut aussi savoir le canadien quand même
annoncé que d'autres mesures qui
seraient dévoilés prochainement régis
attendre de voir qu'est-ce qu'ils vont
propose
en attendant ben moi j'ai peut-être
quelques suggestions pour le canadien
on sait le hockey c'est un sport qui
particulièrement populaire chez les
autochtones on compte d'ailleurs de
nombreux joueurs qui se sont illustrés
dans le hockey
évidemment on à carey price qui est dans
la ligue nationale pique un peu comme le
dieu des dieux des joueurs de rock et
autochtone monde aussi nos vedettes à
nous ici je pense à francis
verreault-paul nouveau philippe six
morts adam jours ben m'hidi zoua chiche
ces gars là ont été et sont encore des
modèles pour plein de jeunes autochtones
ils ont commencé à jouer dans des arénas
dans leur village qu'ils ont fini par
jouer dans la ligue junior majeur ici au
québec puis dans d'autres ligues
professionnelles au canada période
allemand ils sont des modèles de
réussite oui mais aussi des modèles de
persévérance
on n'a pas de questions à se poser il ya
du talent dans le sport chez les jeunes
décédés jeune autochtone
c'est pour ça que je trouvais ça
intéressant de voir des équipes
sportives comme le canadien investir
dans nos communautés
ça peut être dans des infrastructures
comme des arrêts nord ou des centres de
conditionnement physique dans de l'achat
d'équipements sportifs pourront jeunes
ou encore dans la création de programmes
de bourses de perfectionnement pour
soutenir les jeunes qui veulent
développer leurs talents joueurs ça
c'est de la réconciliation concrètes
jusqu'à la fin de semaine dernière le
canadien tirait de l'arrière pire
finalement décidé d'emboîter le pas vers
la réconciliation
d'hui ce que je souhaite c'est qu'ils
prennent de l'avant ce qu'il devienne un
modèle pour les autres qui regardent
pour que d'autres équipes sportives ici
au québec et au canada se disent nous
aussi on veut pousser la réconciliation
plus loin
sur ce je vous dis go habs go
à bientôt pour un reportage